hey friends and welcome back to Deep
dive the weekly podcast where every week
it's my immense privilege to sit down
with academics and authors and creators
and entrepreneurs and other inspiring
people and we find out how they got to
where they are and the strategies and
tools we can learn from them to help us
build a life that we love Carrie Rose is
the 29 year old co-founder and CEO of
the creative agency rise at seven
working with some of the biggest brands
in the world including Asos and
Playstation the company's grown to over
9 million dollars and now carries
expanding the company to the us as well
at one time I saw someone and they was
like what are you doing I thought I own
my own businesses are amazing Anne but
yeah yeah I've got office in New York
I've always been like what now this
conversation with Carrie completely blew
my mind because she is an absolute
Powerhouse when it comes to sales and
marketing and public relations PR stuff
in particular and a bunch of cool things
that she's learned around advertising
and marketing as she's been growing her
business if we was running misguided
marketing strategy this is what we would
do so often we have to come up with PR
idea social ideas strategies of how we
can convert customers better than they
are currently and things like that
Carrie is also a champion for diversity
and inclusion in the workplace and she's
made it a priority to create a company
culture that uplifts and values all
voices we also talk a little bit about
teenage Carrie and the disadvantages and
struggles that she faced earlier in life
growing up in a disadvantaged area and
dealing with grief from a very young age
and how all of that stuff played a role
in her journey to becoming the CEO and
co-founder that she is today I live in a
cancer State on my life so people didn't
go to UNI where I was from and I made it
and I did it and I proved everyone wrong
he would just be so proud so so but I
don't get me emotional he will just be
so proud and I think it's just because
he knows how resilient I am
um oh my God why am I crying what the
hell at the moment according to the
YouTube analytics 81 of you who are
watching this on YouTube have not yet
hit the Subscribe button and so if
you're for example in the now 81 of
people who are watching this on YouTube
but who are not subscribed to the
channel I would love it if you could do
so and would be awesome to get that
number down to 50 and it would be cool
to get like 50 50 sub non-sub ratio just
just for fun all right Carrie thank you
so much for coming on podcast thank you
uh so much to dig into with your story I
wonder if we can start with what were
things like when you were in school
because I guess kind of stunning were
there often kind of paints an
interesting picture of how people grow
okay growing to become entrepreneurs
sure
um I was the typical loud I wouldn't say
naughty kid but I would say cheeky so I
didn't really do anything like really
annoy but I was the class clown like
lots of friends very popular you know
like having fun and all that sort of
thing but I was always that kid at
school that was quite I guess couple
people called me lucky because I never
revised I never really kind of read
books or studied or did my homework but
I always got really good good grades so
teachers hated me for it which is really
weird
um I remember the day that I collected
my gcses my English teacher threw the
envelope at me and she was like how the
hell have you done that and I was like I
opened it and I got like an A and I was
like I don't know so I was quite lucky
but I do think it was just I was I was
often told by my teachers I was a very
good blogger and I used to think that
was an offensive thing but I actually
took as a compliment
um because I was I was able to tell
really good stories through English or
math or whatever it was
um so yeah I was kind of like quite
cheeky at school got in a bit of trouble
I guess just by kind of like taking a
lot of friends on the journey with me
and you know not really focusing on
class but I ended up doing quite well
grades-wise so I think that's a lucky
thing so if um let's say 16 year old
Curry could have seen you now would she
have been like surprised at uh kind of
you becoming an entrepreneur or would
have been like oh of course that was
gonna happen 100 I think yeah
I think like people thought I would more
than likely I don't know not like down
talking working as a waitress all my
life but like just kind of I was more
about my friends than actual education
or career or anything like that it was
all about having fun and so I think yeah
looking back people would be surprised
and actually they are like I have a lot
of teachers that I you know when you see
a teacher in Tesco and they're like
hello I haven't seen you for a while and
one one time I saw someone and they was
like what are you doing I thought I own
my own business and oh amazing and when
I started describing it then oh you
really well but yeah yeah I've got an
office in New York I've got something
like what
so that was like yeah I think if we look
back and think like myself when I was 16
or myself you know or teachers or
anything yeah I think they'll be very
surprised at where I'm at right now oh
fantastic so that's that's very like
refreshing to hear like um I've
interviewed a bunch of entrepreneurs on
the podcast like I'd say 95 of them are
like hustling selling when they
were younger or like building websites
or like doing business from the age of
13. yeah and so it's unusual to speak to
someone for whom that would have been a
complete surprise yeah um so we'll
definitely talk about how how that kind
of changed along the way so it sounds
like in school you were the popular one
you managed to kind of black your way
into good grades yeah if I can kind of
phrase it in those terms and then you
decide to go to university yeah well
funny enough so my family where I come
from and we're not very wealthy no one
went to University to be honest I didn't
even know what university was I remember
getting really good grades and went and
doing a levels and I didn't at the time
knew what I wanted to do so I remember
going to my mum and saying Mom I don't
really know what to do and she said okay
well when you don't know what to do you
need to spread spread it out go study
business go study a language so what I
studied was business Spanish media
because I like to be creative and
psychology you know wide variety of
subjects
um went to college and studied that and
ended up getting really good grades
again so I got like a b b something like
that and I remember my teacher pulling
me aside and saying Carrie what you're
going to do now I was like I don't know
what what do I do I apply for jobs and
she was like have you thought about uni
I was like what's uni I didn't even know
what it was like none of our family had
been to UNI no one spoke to me about uni
and I was like well you've got really
good grades to get into one of the top
universities you know Leeds University
was always one that I looked at at the
time and it was like you should apply
how do I apply so she actually stayed
with me till like 10 p.m kind of thing
we wrote These I don't know what it was
called at the time but like you know
like a cover letter kind of yeah apply
for uni and um I got in I got into the
top uni
um so yeah I remember going home and
saying to my mom I think I'm gonna go to
UNI she's like what you can't go to you
you can't look after yourself because I
was a bit of like messy room kid you
know like that type of kid
um and yeah I packed my bags and moved
to leaves and I never went back nice
so as you can see it was very much like
unplanned yeah Whirlwind and that's
still what I'm like today
what was the rest of your like friends
like were they all going to UNI or was
it that like an unusual thing for your
friendship group yeah quite usual and I
was like a typical kind of kid that had
a lot of friends that maybe felt
pregnant at a young age and probably
came from Council I live in a council
state all my life so people didn't go to
UNI where I was from and if you did you
was usually part of like a rich family
if that makes sense
um so I did have one friend that went to
UNI but she was a couple of years
younger than me so she kind of went
after me and actually I influenced her
to do that but most of her friends
didn't and so it was quite a scary thing
for me to do and but one thing I am is
extremely confident and that's
definitely part of what my dad drilled
into me I just I was like yeah I can go
Judy I can do that like I always believe
I can do anything and that's the mindset
I had even my you know whatever held me
back I can still do it so um yeah
despite friends not really following me
on that journey and I went off alone
that's what I remember that you said
your your dad drilled it into you what
do you mean
so we're a big family so I have six
sisters we all start with the letter c
we'll call ourselves a killer
Kardashians
um wild household as you can imagine so
my dad obviously with loads of girls in
the house
um we're all very different so some of
them have big families or loads of kids
um my mum was always really weird hard
working and that's what inspired me and
I guess I'm the youngest out of the six
um and those my sisters didn't
necessarily end up in successful jobs
didn't really build careers for
themselves and my dad always drilled it
into me at a young age he's like whisper
in my ear when I was like seven you're
different you're gonna be good you've
got you know stick to it stick to it you
like stay focused don't let anyone tell
you you can't do anything so you drilled
that into me
um and even him so he like kind of like
ran a business himself he was a bit of
like an old school farmer and he ran a
business himself to a point where when I
used to come home from school he used to
have like cash lying around the house
and he used to go around count it and
that's how I look at maths so like he he
just kind of gave me the confidence that
I could achieving things that makes
sense
um and he was one that drilled into me
and I don't know why he took a lightning
to me specifically as the young baby
because he I was Daddy's girl but my mum
always said he stuck to you differently
like he's like he saw something in you
so but I think that's what gave me that
confidence to to go and go get it
basically yeah yeah it sounds like both
your parents were pretty supportive then
yeah I'd say so uh it's it's quite a
drastic I guess background because
um so obviously he gave me all this
confidence and stuff my Dad and Mum
broke up when I was like what 12 but
they still stay friends which was really
nice to see and but then my dad had a
sudden heart attack and died and
obviously for me who was like Daddy's
girl that like turned my world upside
down but I think so obviously this was
the time I was 15 so what would I have
been doing a levels then yeah so yeah
that was that yeah it was just before A
Levels yeah it was it was GCSE
um so when I got my good grades and when
everyone was like oh you should go to a
levels and I was obviously just a little
bit like a whirlwind child of like what
should I do next but obviously he was
that motivation of yeah I can do this so
I think that really was like
the thing that driven me to keep going
and you know you can achieve anything
and I think when you do have someone
like a family member pass or like a dad
or like a parent or anything I think you
end up doing it for them rather than
anyone else so I think that's a big
driver especially when I was younger
yeah
well that
that must have been really tough when
you were 15 to cope with that oh yeah
yeah how did you cope with it what was
that like
I didn't for a long time I'd never lost
anybody so like you know when people
have like a grandma that's died or like
I never even had like a grandparent die
so that was like really hard
um and especially because it weren't
planned he just had a heart attack and
died so for me like my dad was my Escape
you know like when the sisters was
arguing in the house because someone had
stole their clothes or whatever it was
or I don't know I I was the young baby I
used to run away and go stay at my dad's
so he was my Escape so I got to a point
where I had nowhere to escape to so I do
think a big part of which one might come
down to later a big part of me leaving
at 17 and going to Leeds and going to
UNI was me escaping a little bit and I
think that is been an interesting Trend
throughout I guess my career of me right
I'm gonna run away and go prove
everybody that I can do this kind of
thing
um but yeah like it hit me hard mostly
because he was like my rock and my
confidence boost and all that sort of
thing
um but I do think it was a big part that
it was like a door opened and said go
run through it in a way oh
yeah I've I've been fortunate not to
have really lost anyone close to me yeah
yet but I know it like it's just a
matter of time I mean it happens to
everyone yeah um so I can't really
imagine having like having to go through
that at the age of 15. I'll tell you a
quick story because it's really
interesting so I remember at school
there was this kid called oh my God
what's his name now Brandon I think it
was and Brandon had lost his mom and dad
in a car accident right and he became
the kid that lost his parents you know
like he had a label on him without
saying it he just was the kid that lost
his parents and I remember I used to see
Brandon in the hallway or in dinner hall
or something and just look at him and
feel sorry for him a little bit like
that's that kid that lost his
parents and I remember the day my dad
died I went to school maybe about two
weeks later and I remember walking
through the hallway and he looked at me
this Brandon and I knew he was looking
at me like the girl that lost her dad I
knew that all of a sudden now I had that
Unwritten label on me in that way and
it's like we connected we said hello
then I didn't really speak to him before
but I think you don't expect parents to
go you don't ever like I never ever
imagined you just don't think about it
oh and I never did especially at 15. so
when it happened it just turned my world
upside down and made me maybe quite
lonely I guess at the time because I was
this baby that looked up you know I
loved my dad and that sort of thing and
but then yeah it was it was a very tough
time
um I guess for a couple of years you
know it was going through I was going
through you know 15 I don't know really
what goes on with hormones and things
like that at 15 but it was the peak time
of obviously getting my grades and you
know where am I going to go next and
making big decisions as a you know a
teenager I guess
um have you got any tips for someone
like if someone's listening to this and
they've recently been through like
losing a parent or someone close to them
anything that you found helpful to help
you get through it
um two things so um one of the things
that I did when I was a kid which is I'm
quite grateful for I didn't know this
but
um when you're under the age of 16 you
actually can get free counseling
um my school recommended at the time so
they got in touch with my mom and said
by the way
um it's like a government thing
um young children who have lost parents
go for grieving you can get free
counseling and it's through the school
so once a week they come in and sit with
your child for an hour and you know talk
through things and one of the things
they talk through which is quite an
interesting concept it made me realize
they basically Drew out
like a road of grief and they said this
road is like a long it's a long road
it's basically it's throughout your
whole life you will grief from losing a
parent and what they said is at the
beginning of the road there's loads of
potholes and these potholes are really
deep to the point where you know when
you drive a bottle it like stumbles you
a little bit but then you keep going
well these potholes sometimes you drive
over it and you fall in it and you don't
come out for months and that's what my
counselor taught me like you are going
to fall into these potholes and you
might be there for a week you might be
there for two months six months whatever
it is but as you go on this I'll cross
this road these potholes get shorter and
sure and they get less so it just
becomes easier they stop tripping you up
as much and that's what grief is it's
not like you're moving on but it just
gets easier it just gets better and
that's one thing that I tried to
visualize with people that have lost
parents or at least lost people close to
them because grief is one of those
things that it does get easier and at
the time you feel like you Will's end
and but that's the first thing I'd
advise and the second thing is this
might sound silly but write letters like
communicate it doesn't need to be
written letters but it could be
communicating in I don't know messages
so like I still had my dad's mobile
number and I'd message him when I was a
kid sometimes and it never went through
you know bounce back but it was kind of
like I was sharing my thoughts at the
time and I think yeah especially like
Lads and boys that they don't
necessarily communicate that sort of
thing they don't show those emotions so
I think find your own way of
communicating and but then also find
your own way of understanding grief so
there'll remember two tips oh
peaceful yeah
um what do you think your dad would say
if you saw how you are now
um foreign
he would just be so proud yeah so so but
don't get me emotional he will just be
so proud and I think it's just because
he knows how resilient I am yeah
um oh my God why am I crying what what
the hell
um I never thought I would I don't even
know you this is amazing
um yeah he would just be so proud also
that I kind of went against the odds you
know like counselor State kid big family
loads of kids no one went to UNI and I
made it and I did it and I proved
everyone wrong I say that though which
is weird because it's like who am I
proving I don't know who I'm proving
me myself I don't know but yeah he'll be
he'll be very proud
um thank you for sharing all that I know
I think it's really important like with
a lot of people's I guess like
especially like you know people who are
like super successful and yeah podcasts
and stuff you often just kind of hear
that see the Highlight Reel of course
you do yeah realizing that there's like
yeah grief and emotion behind it yeah
and everything
um okay so you get through your gcses
yeah you get through a levels and you
decide to go to Leeds yes what did you
study
um it was actually classed as New Media
Communications basically media but it
was the digital version it was the first
year that the media so when you studied
media at Uni it was often thing like
filmmaking podcasting things like that
you know journalism and stuff well it
was the first year when digital started
to become a thing so I was very lucky
actually to have spotted it because it
was the only course in the whole country
that did this and but it was New Media
digital channel so I studied social
media I did things like animation Motion
Graphics learn how to use new technology
learn about the internet and Safety and
Security I did a bit of web development
so very kind of like a technical course
um which I loved because I kind of could
apply you know things that I'm excited
about AI Innovation strategy that sort
of thing but then
um also be quite creative as well yeah
so at that point you're studying the
subject and like what are you thinking
about
um what you want to be when you grow up
still have no idea okay completely no
idea there was a point where I developed
a website which was the worst website in
the world but I remember thinking I'm
going to start a development agency and
I'm going to build websites and make
loads of money and I think it's because
I met some kid who came into class one
day and he said that he makes websites
and he Ian himself like 10 grand or
something I'm thinking oh let's make
some money that's what I want to do
um I ended up paying him like a 100 quid
to do my project work and he did it and
I got really good grade but yeah
um I was still unsure at that time
exactly what I wanted to do so again
figuring it out as I as I went I guess I
have this motto see where the wind blows
me
and that's what I was doing at the time
okay so then three years at University
yeah how was that experience overall
um wild yeah
oh this is an interesting story
so
I started University and I moved into
Halls as everybody does but one of the
biggest mistakes that I made is I
remember thinking I really want to live
somewhere nice and make nice friends and
have a nice apartment you know like be
someone I I'm not like I come from a
counselor state but I want to live in a
knife apartment in Leeds so there was a
certain uni Halls that was a bit more on
the higher price
um and I'm gonna thinking that looks
nice I'll just get some jobs to be able
to afford it but that looks like the
perfect place to go
so I applied to stay there and I got in
you know to into the halls and I moved
into this um amazing halls and this
beautiful like nicest Apartments like I
stayed in for a uni Hall whereas some of
some of the people that I made friends
with at Uni they were staying in some
really bad places you know and but one
thing I really made a mistake about is I
ended up being
like I guess grouped into halls with
some of the richest people in the
country oh okay so culturally there's a
massive Clash right I was the standout
you know councilor State kid surrounded
by people with Rich families who their
parents was paying for their halls and I
was there like working in bars trying to
figure out how to pay for it that was
one of the biggest mistakes I made but
also if I reflect it I learn a lot I
learned about different people and I've
never been surrounded by people that you
know some of their parents were
multi-millionaires billionaires and I
was in these halls with these people
lived with them for a year and it was
very difficult because they had
different perceptions of money and you
know I was there working like hard to
kind of like fund University you know
didn't get a penny from parents or
anything like that
um whereas they was a little bit
different so it was interesting kind of
time because I I guess I felt like I
needed to keep up with them and
therefore I just worked hard to be able
to do that
um but I guess after that first year
ended I ended up moving with some of my
friends off my course yeah um but yeah
that was an interesting decision I made
a few months ago I interviewed a
psychology Professor who studies luck oh
wow and he's written books and papers
and stuff where he boils dirt luck down
to four things basically that lucky
people do that unlucky people don't yes
and one of those is striking up
conversations with people in trains and
coffee shops and that kind of thing yeah
because you just never know where it's
going to take you 100 yeah is that
something that that's sort of carried on
in the rest of your life yeah all the
time yeah I I met someone today in an
Uber um it was a taxi driver he was like
oh where are you going today and I said
about work and I had a meeting with
Amazon and all these sort of things and
he said what do you do and he ended up
being a videographer and um we exchanged
names and added each other on LinkedIn
and someone that I might be able to work
with one day but those don't come about
to Everyday People you just got to be
able to have the confidence to talk to
people and be open-minded and welcoming
as well so I do think because of this
kind of like I don't know more than this
about me maybe I am quite easy to talk
to and so that also is a good part of
how I get good opportunities is people
just feel okay to be able to chats
Ministry or whatever yeah we always like
this so is that something that you have
to develop over time always like this
yeah my mum said when I was a kid she
was like you talk to everybody she was
like you would just make conversation
with people in Tesco like as a like five
year old you know run around but I was
the type of person that also didn't like
to not be in the know she said you would
stay up late so save my mum had friends
around you know for tea and drinks and
stuff and my bedtime would say eight
o'clock she says you would not go to bed
you would sit you'd even sit outside the
door so they'd shut the living room door
and I would sit listening because I just
wanted to hear what adults talked about
she was like you were so curious
inquisitive confident but you loved
being around people so I do think
um that was maybe a big part of I guess
who I am today yeah let's say you had um
a junior team member or something who's
like
um who admires like your ability to talk
to everyone yeah
and and they're like Carrie how do you
how do you do it how do you just strike
up a conversation with someone that you
just remember they've just met can you
think of any like I guess the strategies
or things that you find yourself doing
that you can wow kind of share with this
person to be like oh that's a really
hard one you know when you just do it it
comes natural to you but I guess
if I think how my mind thinks when I see
someone I usually see something that I
can identify with so usually I'll see I
don't know
I saw someone a girl the other day on
train and she was on
um a new look website and she it looked
like she worked in marketing and she was
doing she was writing like notes down
for marketing and I basically said oh um
on the train I was like do you work at
new look
um she says yeah yeah and I said oh do
you know blah blah because I know
someone who works at New Look in the
marketing team so I guess what I try to
do is identify me and them together and
see if I can strike a conversation all
the time so I guess it's just spotting
something that I can either add value to
her day in some way
um so that's one of the things that I
can if I could see myself doing it all
the time well in in that context it's
very easy for you to just be on your
phone you're super busy you probably get
tons of emails and messages and stuff
like what is it that lock up yeah tutor
like yeah actually be like oh do you
work at New Look rather than just like
stuck on the phone I guess maybe I'm
quite like nosy like inquisitive like I
guess that is the thing about me like
um I do ask a lot of questions like I am
that type of person
um
I'm just curious I think
even down to kind of like the people in
this room and like earlier on like in
the lift and stuff like the first thing
I looked at is like I want to know who
they are what the name what do they do
um I think that's I guess it's just a
natural part I guess of me in a way yeah
I mean it seems like that skill has
really served you well yeah I think so
reflection now yeah I've realized that
so you're doing the six month unpaid
internship sort of thing with this with
his Google chap yeah yeah well why are
you still at Uni yeah how are we how are
you how are you doing that like
um to be fair I think it was when
um it started to quiet down you know in
the summer period it was like coming to
the end and then it went somewhere so it
was during that period so I was meant I
was able to manage it absolutely fine
um but I also was like oh no I need
money to pay for rent so I actually
ended up working in wetherspoons at the
same time
with Google
and and you said that you got obsessed
with search yes that's a bit random like
yeah I was I was looking up your agency
and it's all like search-based stuff and
I've not come across to that adjective
before in terms of kind of marketing
agencies yeah because I mean I know
loads of agencies specialize in
Performance Marketing yeah but none that
specialize in search yeah so like where
did the obsession with search come right
it's a bit random yeah it is right
um oh God it's interesting actually I
think it was because one thing I learned
is
um
when when with the Google 360 guy he
basically said if businesses do the
video like add video to their website um
of you know their 360 view of their Cafe
Google then puts them up on listings
when it comes to local search so if you
was to look for a I don't know say if
you're looking for a certain Cafe in
London their chances of getting higher
up on Google
um is bigger because they have this
video content so I was like what so you
can actually influence what comes up on
Google and I was like yeah and I was
like that for me is a money making way
and I was just obsessed with it in that
way and so I remember there was a module
that you didn't have to take at Uni but
I decided to take it like an extra
module it was for SEO and SEO didn't
understand what it meant but it meant
search engine optimization and
essentially what they did is they years
ago they taught you how to actually get
websites to rank high on Google by doing
they call it black hat stuff so black
hat is things you shouldn't really be
doing to manipulate Google and it was
things like write a load of keywords in
white text on a white background so
Google can see it and things like you're
talking about certain content when
actually users can't see it so I learn
about all these different clever ways of
manipulating Google and then that's when
I become really obsessed with arcade
well how is people actually doing it the
right way and that's when I started to
look into actual jobs of this I was like
I'm going to teach myself I guess how
did you clock that this was oh I can
make money in doing this I think because
it was new I think it was because it
excited me that nobody else was doing it
I think that's probably something that
will come up in this conversation even
more is like I always spotted what
everybody else weren't doing
um so if somebody else was doing that
then I want to do something that nobody
else is doing and that's really what set
me out to be like unique
um so I think at that time not many
people was talking about search engine
optimization but you could just see the
budgets was getting bigger and bigger so
like remember that content job that I
wrote um started to get where I wrote
about horses that I realized that was an
SEO job so I was writing content for
websites to get them higher rankings for
certain horse content and I was like
wait there's money in this and I was
like wait and actually people aren't
that good at it like they're doing basic
stuff really so yeah I kind of started
to teach myself in my bedroom watching
YouTube videos you know reading books
and Twitter and all that sort of thing
and I just kind of got my put myself out
there to learn as much as possible at
this new thing that no one else was new
about all right we're just going to take
a quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is huel now
this is very exciting because I've
actually been a pain customer of huel
since 2017. I started eating Hill in my
fifth year of medical school and I've
been using heel regularly ever since
because you know I like to be productive
I you know my calendar is full with a
lot of things and often I don't have the
time or don't make the time to have a
particularly healthy breakfast or a
particularly healthy lunch and heal is
fantastic for those occasions because
it's 400 calories they've got tons and
tons of different flavors my favorite
flavor is salted caramel because for
that you get 400 calories you also get
40 grams of protein super hard to get
enough protein in my diet these days
especially with trying to get hinge and
working out he'll just make sure that I
get at least those 40 grams in the 400
calories and it's got 26 different
vitamins and minerals which really helps
with the whole healthy balanced diet
thing as well now I don't use heal with
every meal I wouldn't recommend using it
with every meal but in those occasions
where you find yourself reaching for a
very unhealthy snack we're about to
order a really unhealthy takeaway it's
just absolutely fantastic being able to
have the option now I use the heel black
edition in the mornings it's very nice I
put two scoops of powder into my little
blender type thing I add water sometimes
a bit of milk and that gives me what I
need but also for lunch I like using the
hewell hot and Savory product they've
got which is basically you add boiling
water to this container of stuff and you
can make yourself like a they've got a
really good cheese pasta type one which
is which is my favorite thing and again
also all of these are nutritionally
complete meals they're all vegan they
all have all these nutrients and
vitamins and minerals and stuff and
they're often reasonably high protein as
well and it's also ridiculously cost
effective like one of these meals is one
pound 68 for a 400 calorie meal which is
like a tenth of the price of what I
would be ordering from deliveroo instead
and so really huel is a perfect
companion for a busy life where you want
to get a lot of things done and you
don't if you don't necessarily have a
lot of time to cook a healthy meal and
deal with all the prep and all the
shopping and all the cleanup then heal
is a great addition to your life rather
than a replacement for all of the meals
in your life anyway if that stands up
your street and you want to try out heal
then if you head over to heel.com
forward slash deep dive that URL is a
special URL which will give you a free
t-shirt and a free Shaker thing with
your first order and so yeah head over
to heal.com forward slash deep dive and
thank you so much heal for sponsoring
this episode this episode is very kindly
brought to you by trading212. now people
ask me all the time for advice about
investing because I've made a bunch of
videos about it on the YouTube channel
and my advice for most people is
generally invest in Broad stock market
index funds which is exactly what you
can do completely for free with trading
212. it's a great app that lets you
trade stocks and funds and ETFs and
foreign exchange if you really want to
and one of the great things about the
app is that if you're new to the world
of investing you can actually invest
with fake money you don't have to put
real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tool into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want now if
you're based in the UK you might be
familiar with the concept of an Isa
which is an individual savings account
which is basically a tax-free wrapper
that you can put money in you can put 20
000 pounds in every year up to 20 000
pounds and it resets every April and
then all that money can grow and it's
completely tax-free for the rest of your
life and if you want to sign up for an
iso you can sign up for one completely
for free also on trading212 so if you
haven't yet filled up your ISO allowance
or at least put some money into your Isa
for this year that might be a good step
forward the app also lets you Auto
invest which is a great thing because
then you can automatically invest a
percentage of your paycheck into the
thing every month and so if you haven't
yet started with investing and you want
to give it a go then you can download
the app on the App Store and if you use
the coupon code Ali Ali at the checkout
that will give you a totally free share
worth up to a hundred pounds it's
available on iPhone and Android and you
can check it out by typing in trading
212 into your respective App Store so
thank you so much trading212 for
sponsoring this episode okay so you're
approaching the end of uni working with
spoons doing this internship at Google
what happens next oh so graduate it
unique get really good grade I can't
remember what I've got now I think I got
first I'm very proud of that moment of
graduating I remember crying with my mom
very very happy and essentially at the
end of University what they do is they
get um businesses local businesses to
come in and do career presentations and
one of the businesses that came in was
an agency called sticky eyes sounds
really weird it's a really weird name
and but they're a marketing agency in
Leeds and they do
um advertising and marketing and PR and
things like that and they was working
with things like ghd like the hair brand
and there was also had like MTV so I
remember them stood in front of our
class talking about what they did and
SEO was one of it and I was like I want
to work that that was like my goal I'm
gonna work there when I graduate and I
was only like three months off
graduating so I went on their website
and I saw that there was a grad scheme
and essentially there was going to be
hiring two people to join their business
and there was a bit of a process around
it so I think there was like free stage
application where you went into their
office for the day and you got to set a
certain task and you had to come up with
an idea ball bar so I went in and I
remember being thinking go in and win it
with personality go in and win it with
energy and positivity because I had good
CV to be fair you know all the
experience and all the free work I was
doing like surely the Google 360 stuff
this is gonna set me in good stead
um so I went to the grad day to go and
like try and win that job and yeah I won
it so I got the job and worked there I
was meant to be working there full time
but I actually ended up getting made
after three months I know so
um while I was there though um the good
thing is I learned so much I remember I
was put on
um ghd and they told me to go and PR
some new launch like product launches
and I thought I do there's like you need
to write press releases and they taught
me how to write press release and all
that sort of thing and then they said
you need to call up journalists and be
you know build relationships and that
was the first time that I ever caught I
thought what do I do when I ring a
journalist I was petrified I remember
the moment that I first rang a
journalist and it was um one of the
first journalists that I rang was
someone at Vogue
and that was that was the toughest yeah
they literally hung up and was like no
go away I was like oh and there's like
no you got to keep going and I was like
okay well who do I ring next and it was
like right so I learned how to kind of
resilience again of like getting told
now and keep going so um I ended up
calling um the sun one day about this
product launch and luckily this girl
called Ellie answered the phone she's
like hi Emily I'm the beauty she was the
beauty editor at the time of the sun I
thought Hayley I thought basically I've
got this product about to be launched
it's for ghd and it's the new it was
when you know like copper gold was like
a new trend and it was like they had the
copper gold hair straighteners so we're
just about to launch it I would love to
send you a pair
funny enough she went I'm a hairdresser
in my spare time I went well that's
low-key again a bit of look
um and she said this weekend it was
um I think it might have been
Glastonbury or Leeds first or one of
those basically and she said I am
actually um doing Ellie Golden's hair
this weekend I will use if you can get
me in by tomorrow morning I'll use the
straighteners and I'll write a piece in
the sun about it I've been thinking
and I hung up I was like went to my boss
I ran to her and I was like you're never
gonna guess what I'm just wearing jeans
at the Sunday I should do that can you
move away move aside we need to we need
to cover this now I remember thinking oh
that's obviously because I've done some
good work but I remember feeling a bit
like oh they've taken that off me like
that was a really good opportunity it
landed in the sun it did really really
well so um and they sold out of ghds at
the time as well so it was really really
nice PR and we ended up doing more more
press coverage and stuff so I guess that
was when I first started to learn what
is PR how to get brand mentions how to
get links back to websites and that's
how we can improve SEO and stuff so yeah
that was my early stages of learning how
to talk about the question so let's say
someone's listening to this and they're
like I've just I want to launch my I
don't know product that
I don't know squeezy handheld b-day for
the toilet or something like that and
they're like but I haven't got an
audience I don't have a YouTube channel
I have a podcast like can I get a
placement in like the sun like is is
that possible for normal people to do it
is
um I guess
so the best way to describe it is you've
got to create a story so a lot of people
listening to me then will probably say
yeah but it's ghd that's easy to get in
the sun you know people love jhd it's a
big brand already so I guess we work
with a lot of style Brands as well and
the biggest thing that I teach a lot of
so we have a team of 50 odd PR's now and
what I teach them is you just gotta
create a story that people will be
interested in it might be something
funny reactive creative like I'm trying
to come up with an idea around this b
day thing or whatever but you basically
ought to come up with something that
people will find either useful engaging
funny or resourceful
um so it could be like a data-led piece
or something that positions you as an
expert but that's how you get PR and so
yeah I've worked with lots of like
Brands everything from Finance which
might be sound boring try travel cars
you know all that sort of thing and
mostly you just have to take the product
the service and create a story out of it
that people actually care about and that
might sound like okay well how do I
create a story and but I think it's
mostly around know what's relevant know
what's relevant in the media what people
are talking about and try and make your
brand relevant to that Trend so it might
be hmm there was a massive Trend
recently around
Facebook and are they listening to us
you know like people's data security and
privacy and things like that and we had
a technology client that basically
looked into
um data security and clouding so
essentially what we did is we did a
study to look at how much data does
Facebook have on US versus Twitter this
is Instagram versus Tick Tock and we
basically created this like online
report which we then pushed out to press
to reveal which app actually knew the
most about us and we ranked them you
know across all these different apps
around the world and that's how we got
press coverage for our brand so it's an
idea of like okay well the the thing
that was bigger at the time was our
Facebook listening to us and we then
turned that into a campaign story
positioned our client as an expert and
able to get you know Mass press coverage
as a result of it nice okay so it's not
about this client has just released a
new Cloud security data interest like no
one gives a no way yes but if you
turn it into something a compelling
piece of content 100 and a lot of
traditional PR's might say
um you need to build relationships and
that's how you're going to get the Press
coverage of your product but I'm like no
people will not cover that they don't
care like even when like we work with
some of the sexiest Brands like fashion
brands and Beauty Brands and they'll
might do a big collection with the
Kardashians or it might even be and you
know another Celebrity Face or anything
like that they still don't care about
that how can you make it relevant to me
because what they need is traffic they
need social shares no one really cares
that you know Chloe Kardashian has done
another range with another fashion brand
but what else can we create that is
going to get the traffic and the shares
for the Daily Mail because we can create
an angle on that so yeah it you've
really got to think about their metrics
and what they care about and how you can
help them hit their kpis too that's
super interesting
um can you think of any other kind of
examples of sort of trying to sell
something boring and turning it into an
interesting story
and um a new maternity range
and clothing brand
yeah yeah oh yeah
um fashion brand um for women and they
was learned launching a new range for
maternity so um when people get pregnant
and there's not much range out there in
terms of dresses and clothes and things
to wear not much choice so misguided a
quite professional brand and they've
actually don't exist anymore but this
was like four years ago
um but what they did is they decided to
launch an actual maternity range that
looked nice for once
um and they said can you mark it can you
prior it and I was like well yeah but
there's loads of maternity Brands out
there there's loads of people that do
maternity clothing so we need to come up
with a story leave it with us
so we then started to look at the media
what are people talking about and one of
the things I don't know do you watch
Love Island I've seen bits of it okay
I can't remember her name but one of the
love Island
um members she was a model on Asos okay
and she was found so somebody watched
the TV show and they basically found her
on Asos in the maternity section and
they was like wait she hasn't got kids
and she had like a paternity bump and
what they revealed is it's fake so
people that wear these maternity they're
models that have these like maternity
shoes they wear fake bumps so it caused
uproar everyone was like oh my God
that's not like realistically what a
woman's body looks like like the fake
bumps how can they realistically show
you know what that dress looks like when
actually we've got bombs and cracks and
all this sort of stuff in all different
places so the the consumer on Twitter
and things like that was screaming out
for realism so I was like I've got a
story I know exactly how to Market our
maternity range we went and actually got
real pregnant models we basically called
up a few models that was pregnant
heavily pregnant with big bumps and we
said we actually want to do a photo
shoot with you and usually models like
what like I've lost my gigs for a year
because I'm pregnant but actually you
want to take photos of me like yeah
because we want to show what real women
look like so we did this whole photo
shoot of maternity range with the
realistic actual real bumps and we
showed it with the stretch marks and
everything and it went all over the
press and it's like the first fashion
brand to do a realistic maternity range
so that's how we added a story to
something that is I guess just a product
launch nice that's really cool yeah
[Laughter]
wow
so let's say I'm a normal person wanting
to Market my B days and I figure out
some kind of some kind of story
I bought one of Amazon the other day and
I've just been sort of Shilling it to
all my friends be like guys this is
um let's Okay cool so let's say I think
okay cool I've got a story angle for XYZ
can I just
click contact us on the sun.co.uk and
email it like how does that work yeah so
when you work in PR you get access to
loads of databases and so databases are
usually quite expensive to kind of get a
handle on but there are some free ones
as well
um so even if you don't go on like
typing on Google free journalist
databases loads of lows on there but
essentially what they do is they give
email addresses for editors across
different niches so if you're looking
for a fashion writer fashion editor or
beauty or travel or Automotive Finance
whatever it is these databases will have
them all listed but what you have to
really do is do your research because
often what PR's go wrong with is they
just send it out to load of journalists
thinking they're going to pick it up but
what you need to do is super targeted so
take the misguided maternity one for an
example everybody that was covering the
fact that the love Island person was
caught with a fake bump I contacted I
pulled a list of everyone that wrote
about that story and I knew that if we
responded to that story with misguided
launch a real range with real bumps that
they're more than likely going to cover
it because they only wrote about it a
week ago so I basically made it super
relevant to the journalists so I'll pull
the list because if you go on like the
daily mail or BBC or anything their name
is underneath like you know I'm the
author of this content so it's finding
those through databases if you can't
find them on databases guess it and then
guess their emails like first name dot
last name at the Sun or whatever
literally yeah it's usually always first
name dot last name at the sun um
mailonline.com so just guess it if it
doesn't work it'll bounce back if it
does win
it's nice and anyone can do this anyone
else
what's the point of a PR agency most
people can't do it because of time yeah
and they can't come up with the ideas
and they haven't got the tools to be
able to and they they struggle to come
up with a good story that people care
about I think a lot of um Brands
internally they obviously day-to-day
work on a brand all the time and they
love it they get to love the brand they
get to love their products and things
like that to a point where they're like
oh my God we need to launch this
depression it's like but no one cares
about it but we do I'm like but they
don't so I think what they need is an
external person to actually say how can
we make this relevant how can we make
this shareable clickable it's buyable
even so I think PR agencies not only
create stories around things but they
actually make it that people actually
want to buy these things as well
something I read on Twitter actually is
like someone said everyone is the same
every product is the same like mostly
you know even down to like phones or
laptops everyone sells laptops you know
in terms of Brands but it's all the
marketing it's the pr angles that makes
it different
um and that's why they use PR agencies
or it's just to create a different angle
on it to create a different story Target
a different consumer and so that's
mostly why Brands need agencies like
that okay tons more questions on the
agency front but before we go there um
I really like that thing you said around
like targeting yeah because I get like
dozens of emails a day from like clearly
copy freaking pasted yeah a dear
influencer we'd love to and I'm just
like why yeah and similarly when we put
out
um job descriptions for people applying
to work with us you get the people that
like one click apply on LinkedIn and
it's just like come on and then the
people that actually take the time to
write an email which is super targeted
which is like 100 times more likely to
get through the door yeah and I don't
know who's telling people that like
spray and pray is a reasonable strategy
but I just love the fact that even in
especially in the like the pr world it's
really about a targeted attack yeah it
to be fair that still happens to this
day so I have my own YouTube channel and
I just basically video behind the scenes
of the agency that wins the fails and
all that sort of thing
um and because I'm on YouTube and I'm
actually on a lot of databases as a an
editor content creator so often
um PR's send me press releases like oh
I've got this new product launch and I'm
like what I'm 18 I'm kind of like some
of my competitors send me their agent
their release pieces and I'm like why
are you doing this because they're not
checking they're just like spraying and
praying so I think it still happens this
day and I think the best agencies are
really good at Super targeting knowing
what people are talking about like
building those relationships with
journalists and that's the thing that a
lot of people just don't put the energy
into doing but I also think even down to
like you know job applications and
things like that all we do so I spoke to
a journalist actually
um they on average get 600 emails a day
oh wow yeah and they cover by the way
around six stories a day yep it's a lot
because we're in a digital world they
need to be producing articles fast if
you work out the average time that's
about an hour an article say I've not
got a long time so you've got to stand
out in the inbox one which is the
hardest thing to do when the 600 emails
you've got to capture their attention
give them everything on a play without
not boring them in you know whatever so
it's a very very tough market for a PR
but you just got to be able to find a
way to do that so um yeah
it's not easy yeah I think part of the
issue that I see is
um
there's a lot of people talking in
videos and courses and stuff around like
the easy way to make money and it's like
oh just copy paste this template stick
it in a mail merge and send it out to
5000 people and someone will respond
it's like no way
it's because people like don't don't
want to do the hard work of actually
yeah taking the time and talking to
someone and finding their email and
figuring out why it's actually
compelling and how to add value I was
actually talking to my PR director the
other day and I so I've worked with him
all of my career so when I worked it I
walked into another job straight out of
sticky eyes a company called branded
three so this is another company that I
had heard about and knew was quite good
at what they did it was actually voted
the best agency in Europe at what they
did and I ended up getting a job there I
was like yes got in straight away and I
think it's the whole Sun thing what I
did there that was like we want you so
we've got a job there
um I walked in and I ended up working
with this guy called will
um and he was the pr director and LPR
manager at the time and essentially we
have worked together for about 10 years
um he's with me now at my company and we
spent 10 years figuring out the best way
to do it 10 years it took us to actually
find out the best way to write a release
the best way to Target press releases
the best way to build a relationship and
efficient ways as well and now so
obviously I'm building my own business
and I'm hiring people 24 7 to the point
where I have people joining the business
and within two weeks they're delivering
like industry-leading results in two
weeks and these are like 21 year olds
like and people like how the hell are
they like learning how to do that but I
think some of the team take it for
granted because what I have to what we
realized the other day is it took us 10
years to give you that resource and
those information of how to do this and
be able to get those results in two
weeks because we didn't get those then
um so yeah I think it takes a lot of
time so you know when you say like
people want quick win strategies it took
me years to figure out how to do it to
the like we're a five star standard now
in my opinion and I'm biased
um but we're a five-star standard now
but it took us a lot of years to get
there
so you do the the job at Sticky eyes for
three months and then you join got made
redundant yep because they lost a client
ah yeah so that's that's why I realized
uh I guess when I got married redundant
I was like crying I was like what I was
doing really well and I thought I took
it personally yeah but they'd actually
lost a client um and that's the thing I
learned about business is they lose
Revenue they have to cut heads and I was
like okay so I learned not to take it
personal
um so I'd heard of another agency called
brand new three and I basically tweeted
the director there I said I want a job
there she won't come in and come chat to
me I went and spoke to her and the CEO
and I got off for the job on the week so
uh yeah I forgot very lucky so that's
also an unusual approach like you didn't
go on the website and like try and apply
it officially and all that stuff yeah
you just a message on Twitter I think
when I'm under pressure I do things out
of the ordinary so for me I just thought
I was under pressure because at number
one I had an apartment in Leeds and my
rent was 850 a month and I was only
earning 80 pound a month at the time I
think it branded sticky eyes so like my
salary is really low but I had a rent to
pay for and so I was under pressure and
I wanted a job fast so instead of just
you know going through careers and doing
you know the typical thing I thought you
know what I'm just going to Tweet you
because she did tweet out the job ad and
I just said I want that job that's mine
can I chat to you and she'd obviously
saw in my bio I worked at the compare
agency so clearly she's going to want to
know what I've got to say
um so yeah
I uh I did that on depression it worked
nice so you got the job and then you're
there for I was there for six and a half
hours around seven years oh wow yeah
long time yeah how was that experience
amazing I learned so much I was very
loyal obviously saying that seven years
is very rare by the way in a marketing
agency typically people stay within
marketing agencies for about two years I
think it's normal two three years so the
fact I stayed there for seven years is
yeah it was a good ride got tracked
really well learned loads
um I started in the industry marketing
things like car insurance
um I worked on gambling so lab Brooks
was one of my accounts which was not the
sexiest I don't know anything about cars
I don't know anything about gambling I
don't bet like it's not my thing but
because I learned how to Market really
tough Brands I can Market anything
in my opinion what are the principles
behind marketing stuff like if we we've
talked a little bit about kind of
creating the story around it yep what
else is there as part of marketing hmm
because I guess that some people like
who don't have that background marketing
can seem a bit but Marketing sales
equals scam equals this is just
it's just hot air they're just trying to
pump up the value of a thing that
doesn't like there's a lot I think
there's a lot of like misconceptions
around what marketing actually is and
I've only recently started actually
diving into this for my business and
being like oh wow people read books
about this these books are really good
yeah what's your strategy when it comes
to marketing so quite a broad question
because
um but I guess my strategy the way that
I think about it is
um generating brand demand I think
um you can pay as much as possible to
get people to see who you are and what
you've got to say so a lot of people put
you know do paid advertising and things
like that and you can pay as much money
to generate customers and it does work
but I think for me I'm more about how do
I build a brand so I don't have to pay
for customers people come to me that's
really what I focus on
um there's a concept um called it's an
advertising concept and it's called The
Purple Cow have you ever heard of it
I've heard of it what is it so basically
it's all around
it yeah yeah I've not read the book so
basically the book Purple Cow
um concept is around standing out and
being different so essentially what he
basically said was when you're driving
along and you see a field of cows you
don't really go oh look a cow you don't
do that you see it every day it's the
same old stuff
but if you drove along one day and
looked in that field and also there was
a purple cow you gotta pull up and
you're gonna go what the hell there's a
purple cow
and that's the thing about advertising
and brand we're being we're consuming
content load of content every single day
like you know even getting here today
the amount of advertising that I see
people don't realize it how many
advertising you see I think you see a
thousand in a day by the way so a
thousand adverts in a day and that could
be on billboards it could be on your
phone on Instagram so you are constantly
consuming content
and the idea is that how do we make sure
we create content that actually people
see and remember it and that's the
biggest thing so there's another and
that's what the purple cow is it's like
if you can build a brand
but will that people actually remember
and see it stands out in a line of 100
pieces of content that's how you're
going to get customers so that's how
people really invest in really stand out
marketing so I guess something like
compare the meerkat yeah is a purple cow
the go compare a singer dude yeah it's a
bit of a person you remember it people I
talk about it it's like annoying but
like yeah but in a still in a memorable
way yes and those are the only two price
comparisons I don't know yeah because
that's those two things yeah yeah and
that's why you remember it but you can't
remember anything else you don't know
like money.co.uk or you know
confused.com these are all like
comparisons oh yeah yeah I remember that
one but it doesn't it doesn't have to be
like oh yeah I've seen an ad for that
somewhere but there was nothing about
that that stood out yeah and take go
compare yeah so um go compare there go
compare their TV ad
um it was remembered but remembered
negatively and what I mean by that is
it's annoying it's a little bit
irritating but it makes you remember it
so there's another fact
um so 20 million is spend no I like 20
billion is spent every single year on
Advertising
89 of that is never remembered at all I
think it's four percent is remembered
positively and seven percent or
something is remembered negatively
but as long as it's remembered
so with 89 if you take I don't know the
mass I'm not very good at off the top of
my head but 89 of 20 billion is a lot of
money that is being wasted every single
year on Advertising by advertising and
marketing that's just never remembered
at all and I think it's because 89 of
people are stupid they don't know how to
Market people so it's a lot of money to
be wasted and I guess when I started to
build my own agency out I needed to go
and find those people that weren't
stupid if 89 of people were stupid in
marketing because they didn't know how
to create an advert that get remembered
there's a very very small pool of people
that knew how to do that so yeah I I
guess when I decided to start me a
marketing agency that's what I focus on
how do I create how do I get those
people to create advertising that's
remembered this purple cow concept
so how are you doing that for something
like Ladbrokes like what though or like
car insurance and stuff like are you
trying to because something like the go
compare man yeah is a bit of a gimmick
but like yes in a way that works but no
one else has really succeeded with by
copying that kind of thing similarly no
one else is trying to do the meerkat
things they're like how how do you even
begin to make Ladbrokes interesting or
yeah some random character it's
interesting Ladbrokes is a difficult one
mostly because I guess the best brand
that can compare it to is like Paddy
Power it's like Paddy Power they do
really well with that sort of thing I
guess they're kind of like they go
compare of the world you know in terms
of they do advertising stunts that are
comical that people share but it's
mostly around for Ladbrokes consistency
so there's a thing called a mental
availability and there's physical
availability so I guess when you walk
down the street in London and you see a
Ladbrokes store that's physical
availability they're available for
everywhere yeah yeah they're everywhere
but then when it comes to mental
availability it's like how do we make
sure that if I say gambling you think
that Brooks yeah or if I say car
insurance you think go compare so mental
availability is the thing that marked is
really a tapping into and so with lab
rugs it's mostly around consistency you
need to make sure that whenever people
are looking at sports content whether
it's you know horse riding football
rugby whatever it is Ladbrokes appear
whether it's tick tock content YouTube
YouTube ads and PR you know where maybe
you're researching of how to place a bet
because you've never placed a bet before
you know touching users at all different
types of the journey so yeah it's all
around how do you appear when people are
looking to make a bet and people are not
just you know making a bet all the time
they might be just scrolling through
sport content so it's all around
consistency of appearing yeah that makes
sense
so that's why you would see like
Ladbrokes and Betfair and Bet365 ads on
the football billboardy type things
around the pitch yeah because they just
want to be like associate that thing
with sports exactly it like if I think
of Razer Brands I think of Gillette yeah
I know that Wilkinson Sword exists but
like I'm never gonna buy it like it's
just like obviously Gillette is like the
good one even though and then you get
ads like uh Dollar Shave Club yeah that
would be like hey just one blade that's
all you need they would then use that to
counter the huge advantage that Gillette
have yeah here's something for you yeah
I saw her actually the day
brand is very very interesting so a lot
of people think brand is that thing you
invest in that is a bit fluffy it's hard
to track and it's hard to measure
however this is why brand is really
important so say if you walked into
Starbucks and there is um two sets of
people in Starbucks sat you know working
at their at their laptops there's
somebody on like a Windows laptop and
there's somebody on a Mac
if you ask someone what do you think
he's working on on the Mac more than
likely say oh he's create a movie or
he's created a you know a film or a
piece of music or something like that
what do you think he's working on on the
on the on the screen yeah especially
it's fine boring here that's why brand
is important because what they do is
associate that person with a job for an
example and straight away you it's an
identity so you buy the identity So when
you buy a Macbook it's because you want
to be seen as a creative so you're you
know same with why you buy Gucci or
Chanel or whatever you want to be
associated with those words then that's
why Brian is really important this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
wework now this is particularly exciting
for me because I have been a full paying
customer of wework for the last two
years now I discovered it during you
know when the pandemic was in the on the
verge of being lifted and I spent like
the whole year just sort of sitting in
my room making YouTube videos but then I
discovered wework and I was a member me
and Angus my team members we were
members of the wework in Cambridge and
they have like hundreds of other
locations worldwide as well and it was
incredible because we had this fantastic
beautifully designed office space to go
to to work and we found ourselves like
every day just at nine o'clock in the
morning just going to wework because it
was a way nicer experience working from
the co-working space than it was just
sitting at home working these days what
me and everyone in my team has is the
all access pass which means you're not
tied to a specific wework location but
it means you can use any of their
several hundred co-working spaces around
London around the UK and also around the
world and one of the things I really
love about the co-working setup is that
it's fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drained just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop with me
I've got some free coffee from there
I'll get a few snacks and it's just such
a great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I've made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being an environment almost
like a library but kind of nicer because
there's like a little bit of soft music
in the background and there's other kind
of startup Bros and creators and stuff
in in there as well and it's just my
absolute favorite co-working space of
all time it's super easy to book a desk
or book a conference room using the app
and it's a great place to meet up with
team members if you're going to
collaborate and you'll live in different
places they've got unlimited tea and
coffee and herbal teas and drinks on tap
and they've got soundproof booths in
which they take Zoom calls and meetings
anyway if you're looking for a
co-working space for you or your team
that I'd 100 recommend we work like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 off your first booking so thank you
so much wework for sponsoring this
episode so you're working at this Agency
for seven years you're learning a lot of
stuff along the way yes trying to make
these kind of somewhat boring clients or
accounts and fun in a nice way yeah okay
so then what happens next how do you
decide that you want to do your own
thing so
um a couple of things happened so I was
progressing quite fast I was one of the
top performers in the team really really
loved it like really really happy
um but what I ended up starting to do is
getting some I I actually um ran a
campaign once that went viral
um and it kind of put my name on on the
radar across the marketing industry so
much that I had money Supermarket One
Day ring up the agency to say they
wanted to work with us the agency that
worked at and they want the ginger hair
girl on the account so it kind of made
me famous a little bit but what that
ended up resulting in is I had a lot of
freelance offers so people was like oh
do you want to do some work on the side
and I'm like yeah how does it work on
the side so I started to do some work on
the sides for a couple of Brands and
there was nothing kind of too crazy just
like you know bits and Bobs here and
there but I ended up starting to earn
more money doing that than freelance so
you remember will who I mentioned
um he was ended up becoming one of my
best friends and I basically said to
Will hey I'm getting that much freelance
work two and a half it with me you get
half I got half and we'll work on this
together and earn some side money and it
paid for things like holidays a nice
handbags you know it was just kind of
like a a side hustle I guess
um but what I realized is I was very
very good at what I did and I was
becoming a lot more in demand
um but what I also saw at the time so
the agency that was currently at branded
three they actually sold so they sold to
a bigger company called edit we got
merged in and then some of the
competitor agencies in the industry also
got sold and merged in and essentially
there was not really a leader anymore
there was not really anybody that led
the market because Brandy three was the
most famous but they'd sold and people
started to leave so I saw a massive Gap
in the market and that's when I started
to think
maybe I could start filling that
um I didn't know where to start with
that yet though it was just a I spotted
the opportunity I don't know where to go
next
funny enough
um I was in work one day and will said
to me Carrie you know I was still the
same kid you know like I was at school
like chatting and giggling or something
he said you should get on TV you should
apply for something like big brother or
The Apprentice so one night I went home
and I had a few glasses of wine with my
friends and basically I applied for The
Apprentice
um and I didn't think anything of it I
actually forgot about it I went to bed
and then the next morning I woke up to
an email from The Apprentice saying
thank you for your application we'd
actually like you to to push you through
um to the first round you need to come
to London on Monday and I was like whoa
I was like what happens what do I do
what do I wear I don't go shopping I
said what do I need and they said you
need to create a business plan like
rapid so I had like two days to create a
business plan so obviously I already
already kind of knew what I did I was
like use what I'm good at
second thing is I spotted a gap in the
market let's expand on that what is the
opportunity for me
um and then I started to think about
products and that price and you know
what I've learned I guess if I'm
building you know seven years of my
career so I started putting a business
plan together and one of the directors
at the agency I worked at Brandon three
he was very kind of like good friends
with me and he's very supportive of me
like often like giving me good like life
advice and career advice so I ended up
messaging him saying I've got a bit of a
secret I've applied for the apprentice
and I've got through to the first round
it's nothing serious yet because by the
way 40 000 people applied that year so
it's a lot of people so I had no idea
where it was going to go so I just said
can you help me put this business plan
together so he said yeah sure and he
sent me a few notes and he said right
what have you done so far and I sent it
over and we built it out basically
I went down to the interview and I'll
not go through everything because it's
it's very very long story because it was
multiple rounds and it was very in-depth
and tiring and but it was very very
interesting but there was one point
where so I remember going down to the
audition
and we there was lines and lines of
thousands of people and what they did is
they put you into categories of 20
people they put you in a room they lined
you up and they basically said one
person out of u20 is going through that
door and they're 19 others are going
through that door and it's up to you
guys who goes through it was brutal
extremely brutal so I remember they put
me in this group of 20 people and they
put you in a room and you spent about
half an hour in the room before you went
into another room to actually do like
whatever was in that room no one knew
what was in that room so I was listening
to conversations and people saying oh I
had a really business and I was like
I don't want a business like and
someone was like oh yeah I'm already
making millions and I'm like oh like I
didn't do any of this year I didn't make
millions yet I've just got an idea
so we gotta put into this room and they
lined us up all 20 of us and on the
floor we all had a number but there was
all mismatch so it might be like one 11
13 21 you know that sort of thing
um and I had number nine
and they basically said right number
three can you step forward you've got
um I think it was 15 seconds
to say why you should go through that
door
so people like uh well I saved a live
and I've done this and I've made money
and there's the right step back
whoa this is bro you didn't have long at
all to prove why you should go for that
door that number 11. so number 11 step
forward and then number 19 and then I
remember I was like maybe like the fifth
person that they said and they said
right number six
no one step forward I was like looking I
was like where's number six
and I looked and I had number six but
because I I actually have number four I
had number nine because it was upside
down it looked like a nine so straight
away people started laughing and I was
like oh no and I went bright red because
I was embarrassed then because I was
like Oh I thought I was number nine and
then anyway so I was like this is where
I started to get under pressure and I
know I work well in pressure
and I stood forward I can't even
remember what I said but I nailed it and
then
okay step back I think I kind of I don't
know I made myself into a I thought to
myself if I'm in that room I need to
stand out personality wise than anything
else my business idea is good enough and
I'll figure that out later on but the
thing I need to do is stand out and I
went in there and kind of really showed
my personality I didn't even blag I
didn't need to sit and talk about my
success I just went in and went in with
my personality and a long story short I
went for all of the 20 people and they
said right number six can you step
forward and I stepped forward they went
you're going through that door everyone
else goes home and what happens is I
went through the door and you're in a
lift and you go up the lift and you hit
the seven floors in this another seven
like second round third round and there
was seven oh it was pretty well so I got
through to the final round got invited
back we did TV you know the intro to
camera like hi I'm Carrie dude I did all
of that and then met the financial team
went through my business plan and they
actually told me to go get private
investment so this was like wow so I was
still at Brandy three and I didn't tell
anybody I only told the director and he
kept it quiet he was like good friend so
he kept it like quiet as a secret
so I went back and I said I haven't got
on the show but they've told me to go
get private investment and somebody who
had followed the process of The
Apprentice basically offered me um some
money not massive money and but enough
money to go and start so I basically
said that's it that's the smart that's
my door open step through it and I did
and I went from there sick yeah that's
so cool
um okay so um
you present the business plan to these
Apprentice guys they say you should get
private investment yes why do you need
investment why not bootstrap and just go
profitable from day one kind of yeah I
could have done
um I guess the investment what it gave
me is the confidence
um to go and figure it out because if it
didn't work no matter like I don't need
to like yeah they owned a certain
percentage of the company a small
percentage but I didn't need to pay that
back
um in that way and so I guess it was
more of like okay if I could get a bit
of a buffer a bit of a pillow to land on
if things don't go okay then that's
absolutely fine so it gave me the
confidence that I had a bit of money in
the bank don't look back and I think a
lot of business owners when they
launched they're constantly looking back
at their bank account can I afford this
kind of I didn't look once something fun
fact I shouldn't really admit but I
didn't look at the bank account once for
the first year I didn't even know my
login
yeah
um but that was a good thing because I
didn't look at whether I could afford it
or not which is crazy like crazy
statement to make
but what I did is I had my face forward
and I was like constant like I can do
anything I can achieve it you know I
don't need anything I've got money
behind me I'll be fine and it weren't a
big amount of money by the way to a
point where
um we ended up giving it back and saying
I don't need it so we did that about
three months in oh okay yeah
um so yeah we ended up being profitable
from day one but what it gave me is
confidence and I do think that is a very
hard thing to get when you're starting a
business is that absolute confidence not
to look back
what did your um so when you were
working at the at the agencies what sort
of salaries were you getting and how did
that change over time over the seven
years my salaries yeah um I guess I
started you know minimum 16 Grand
something like that a year um and I went
I can't remember what highest I went I
remember at 35 Grand okay so that's the
maximum I earned at that time
um and that was when your freelancing
company you're like oh hang on like I'm
making one 3K a month for freelance yeah
so that's cool yeah literally
um so yeah I was earning more money then
and I thought you know what I can go and
start my own business and probably earn
money a lot faster yeah so I guess it
was a it was a way for me to be My Own
Boss
um I was I was also quite not for sure I
won't say frustrated but I was like
there's a lot of things that I would
have changed in that business at the
time at Brandon three like I was like oh
what about this you know and you get to
know a lot and you're like well I would
if I don't you you know if I was the CEO
running this company or the director or
whatever I'd be doing this I'd be doing
that so often I was I had ideas to
improve the business that didn't you
know I was a nobody really so I guess I
thought well if I go and start my own
agency in own business I can just roll
it out and no one tells me no so yeah I
was I was a bit like that
what was the business plan like at the
time what was the
I wanted to start a search agency which
both drove demand for Brands but also
captured it off the back of it so I'll
tell you a story of how I come up with
that concept so it was 2000 I think it
was 2018 or 2019 it was the year of the
John Lewis Christmas ad where Elton John
featured in it essentially
um I was tracking the John Lewis
Christmas ad I didn't work on the ad but
I was tracking it because I wanted to
know how people behaved after they saw
the Christmas ad because I was like I
was obsessed with it how do people
behave when it comes to search on social
behaving buying all that sort of thing
so essentially Elton John on the TV ad I
think they spent about 10 mil what year
on the ad and Elton John was playing the
piano he was a little kid and he you
know turned into the artist he was with
thousands of fans screaming in the
audience
and one of the things John Lewis didn't
realize which I was tracking is searches
straight after that advert got released
for pianos went up from 250 000 a month
to 500 000 a month they doubled it
actually went a little bit higher it's
about 181 increase
so John Lewis was spending all this
money on a TV ad to try make sales of
John Lewis products but what they was
actually doing is driving demand for
pianos that's why I I typed in piano I
searched piano as well then I was like
damn I wouldn't get better at the piano
so I typed in pianos in Google to see if
John Lewis come up because that would be
clever you know it's been doing the TV
ad generating demand for pianos and then
selling them at the back end John Lewis
were nowhere to be seen so people was
generated these brand was generated in
search demand and not even captured on
the other side so I just knew there's a
massive Gap where actually someone an
agency could work in the brand PR
advertising whatever generating demand
for products but we could also do SEO
and content to capture that demand as
well so essentially that was the
business plan I'm going to create an
agency which took so there's two sides
of advertising really there's creative
advertising traditional advertising and
then there's digital performance and
they don't really sit close together
they're quite separate and at the time
four years years ago I was like wait
what if I put those two together what if
I hired 10 people from advertising 10
people from search and digital and put
them into a business I wonder what
happens and so I did and it made magic
how many people did you need to get it
off the ground
um there was two of us okay so a fun
story
um you know the director who I got to
write the business plan I texted him and
said do you want to come with me he's
like what he um he actually just found
out his wife was pregnant
massive risk for him
um and he I I need the money this guy
was a director he's on six figure salary
already and I wouldn't so I was like
well you know I I was a lot more free
and risk you know risk real and all that
sort of thing whereas he had a lot to
lose so at first he turned me down and
declined it um and then two weeks later
he actually called me back up and said
that offered does it still stand Let's
Do It
um there was a few reasons why I decided
to change my mind I think it was like
changing the market you know probably a
few late night conversations with
himself like motivating can he do it can
he not
um so yeah he decided to join
um and we launched the business within
two weeks
um of starting basically creating the
business plan and then launched it to
the market basically how did you launch
it
um at the time and we did a big post on
social media that so obviously he was a
director at the agency and I was just
you know a normal creative person and
the fact that we had joined together
after
um they merged and sold it was a bit of
like a well who's what's next it was
like somebody needed some new news to
the market if that makes sense there was
not a leader anymore so somebody needed
to just dropped it in the way so we
basically did like a social media
strategy where we did this big
announcement on social media that me and
him had joined forces to create an
agency that no one's actually done
before brought advertising together and
searched together
um another thing we did it was only it
was actually on the day so this is very
very ballsy so the agency that we worked
at brander 3 they owned an event called
search leads and it was basically like a
conference so every year they have
people stood on stage teaching people
how to do SEO and content so that year
was
um I think myself and my co-founder was
talking on stage that day well when they
heared that we was leaving to start our
own agency we thought they would take us
off the lineup because obviously there
was like wait this is kind of a
competitor you know we can't have them
speaking on at our conference but the
CEO was like you know they're only a
small agency two of you
um so I think it's fine we'll still have
them talk but we saw that as an
opportunity so Stephen was the my
co-founder he was the first person to
open the conference and usually we
opened the conference with her hi
welcome to search leads you know this is
Brenda 3's conference blah blah we
opened it with so my business called
Riser seven and he opened it with a rise
at seven logo hmm and that's yeah very
ballsy
I was not ready for that that was not my
idea
um but it was the best thing we did it
was very ballsy or probably lost a few
friends out of that through the last job
and I remember him saying that he was
going to do that and I was like oh
really I thought oh I'm nervous I was
petrified I remember I was like in the
audience because I knew I had to talk
later on in the day and I was like
really you're gonna do that he was like
you know Purple Cow you're gonna have to
stand that out you gotta take risks
sometimes and so yeah he stood on that
stage and he introduced Ryan's at seven
and it was a very very ballsy move and
but what that meant was we got 4 000
people followers overnight on Twitter
because people was in the audience this
conference bear in mind was a few
thousand people big and people said oh
my god really ballsy move and what it
showed is we were ready to disrupt and
that's what the market needed at the
time so I think we had to do that we had
to do something big nice okay that's
cool so you launched this thing within
within two weeks of making the business
plan yes and like presumably you start
getting clients from day one yeah we got
a couple of clients and these are very
small clients that probably no one's
ever heard of so he was working with
like a small safety training company and
and like an exam paper company that did
like exam training and things like that
so it was very small
um not really enough to cover both of
our salaries he had to take a massive
pay cut I actually got pay rise which is
funny because obviously I was only on 35
Grand so I got a little bit of a rise
and because I was paying myself you know
a bit more but it only just covered our
salaries
um but then we had a bit of an
opportunity so essentially we I got in
following the announcement I got invited
to speak at another conference and
because they was interested in how how
do we bring SEO and you know brand and
advertising together in those ways in PR
so I got invited to speak on stage and
because of all the noise about us on
social media which literally was organic
because we did a bit of balls in
marketing
um thousands of people turned up
literally somebody took a picture like
Carrie have you seen like the room
you're about to talk in house like
backstage there was like there's people
queuing out the door sitting on the
floor I was like oh my God and I was
like well I best go in there and nail
this then and usually it is people
marketers it's not really my audience
that they're not going to buy from us
they're there to learn so I didn't
really think about the opportunities
that could come out of that well I stood
on stage did a really good talk for
about 40 minutes
um and I got very lucky again because in
that audience was the head of digital a
misguided
and that's the first client real big
client the brand first brand we won so
what happened was I did I did the
presentation and I got I come off stage
to an email in my inbox and it was the
head of digital misguided and he said hi
I've just heard you talk and I thought
he's brilliant I haven't seen a tour
like that for a long time I haven't
really seen anyone think about it in the
way that you guys are thinking about it
can you come to our office on Monday and
we want you to pitch for us so we've
actually already chosen agency to do
Global Marketing for misguided but you
guys seem a bit of a wow card I was like
whoa I misguided I've never done fashion
you know my most of my career I did car
insurance and gambling and things like
that like but I was like if I can gamble
if I can Market gambling I can Market
anything so
um what I did is I called up
um will who worked at Brandon three and
a couple of other friends and I said I
need you to come to a meeting with me on
Monday and pretend to be my staff
and they was like okay I'm in and I said
I need to look bigger than I am because
right now I'm only two people me and my
co-founder but I need to look like I've
got staff that could be able to take on
a client like this so we went to the
pitch and admittedly I was very
transparent and said these people don't
work for me but I said um but if you if
we win this account I'll hire them
tomorrow and we won it we won the global
account there and then on the spot and
that changed everything for us so we
actually got featured in like um
prolific North which is like a marketing
publication that you know rise at seven
of just one misguided like a two-person
agency how the hell have they done that
and within 24 hours we got we got a call
from pretty little thing and the boohoo
group the full group and said like
get rid of misguided and we'll offer you
dubbing them out of money we had
PlayStation and all these Brands get in
touch with us literally within weeks
um but we actually declined the boohoo
offer
um because we're loyal you know to
misguided it was our food we didn't want
to let them down you know blah blah so
we stayed working with them for a year
and then we decided to go for PLT after
a year but
um yeah from that moment we had maybe 65
Brands get in touch with us everything
from made.com Halfords
Odeon Cinemas it just flew it was the
fastest Pace like growth that I've ever
seen so we went from two people we hired
like seven then we went to 25 and then
we got to 100 literally within like
seven months or so it was crazy and that
was during pandemic or pandemic so we
obviously June 2019 is when we launched
so when pandemic hit went like January
March of twenty yeah I remember hearing
noise about in January thinking it was a
you know flu or something and then March
is when it got serious so we had about
six months I guess of normality normal
you know running a business of normal
life and then I remember when the
pandemic hit I remember calling my mum
because we was going we was doing really
well
um and I remember calling my mum saying
mum I think I'm going to lose effort or
not overnight and she was like it's okay
and I was like do I take my because I
was hiring at the time because I just
won all this work loads of clients I was
like do I take the job ads down not
higher like and I remember my business
part was like no we're not taking it
down we look forward we don't look back
we never have done keep going and we
just grew we just grew rapidly during
the pandemic and I think when when the
pandemic hit I think we had about 17
staff and we went from that to 70.
literally within a few months
what was it that helped you win that
initial misguided pitch
and how does that work when they say
pitch for us are you trying to like put
on a slideshow or something and be like
hey this is why you should hire us yeah
okay um so typically what happens is
um they invite agencies in so maybe say
five they'll invite five agencies in and
you have to show why why you but it's
less about you but more about what ideas
you have for them so you have to give
away a lot for free it might be ideas
strategies you have to do a bit of
analysis into what are they doing right
what are they doing wrong so we
basically put a bit of a deck together
of if we was running misguided marketing
strategy this is what we would do and it
basically they was like yeah you've hit
the nail on the head so often we have to
come up with a PR idea social ideas and
strategies of how we can convert
customers better than they are currently
and things like that so usually you have
an hour to pitch
um I think we went in for about an hour
an hour and a half and then we walked
away and we got an email saying we won
it okay changing gear slightly um so
we've we've got 70 people in the team so
far at the moment
let's say uh as a bit of a thought
experiment
you were allowed to clone like three of
them oh a million times over and you're
like like if you think of the people
that I like I would clone you in a
heartbeat add to my business what are
the what are the characteristics of
those like clonable top performers oh
um
and I guess I'm asking for someone
listening to this is like you know if
they're in a job and they want to kind
of stand out or drawing a new job or
anything like that like what are the
things that someone like you would be
looking for as a business owner tenacity
tenacity is that the word where you push
through I think there's not enough
people in businesses that just keep
pushing like even if you get a pushback
no you can't do that or you know it's
going to take time go no we'll figure
out another way and I think those are
the people in my business that I go yes
I'm so glad I've got you because I think
people who don't take no for an answer
or don't take pushbacks for an answer
are the ones that succeed 100 so I think
tenacity
um the second thing that I would do is
clone anybody that is super curious so
one of the things I do I test people in
job interviews and I go have you got any
questions and if they go no I don't
think I have
they don't get the job
anybody that wants to be successful or
is you know going to be good at their
job are curious they're going to have a
million questions and I want a million
questions I want them to ask me Carrie
what do you do day to day or how much
money do you make or you know um what
are the problems in the business or
what's the first thing you would like me
to do or whatever it is people who ask
questions they're the ones that succeed
the most and they're the ones that do
well in things like pitches if they're
asking their clients questions all the
time tell me about this tell me about
that how do I know about this like like
how do I learn as much as possible about
you and your company they're the ones
that succeed so I think those are the
two things that I mainly focus on is
tenacity and curiosity
um and then lastly I think it's just
enthusiasm I think people that are just
every day positive about their job and I
think obviously we're not all positive
you know I go through days of negativity
and feeling no I don't want to really go
to work today whatever it is but I think
if you have a positive outlook mostly on
life I think you can change the
perception of most most things basically
can you think of many people that you
have that have those category those
characteristics but you would still say
are underperforming like is there a
because we've we've talked about kind of
like personality traits tenacity
curiosity and enthusiasm yeah is there
like a kind of tangible performance
element as well that's Decor related
from those things or do you find that it
kind of tends to go together
tends to go together I think there's a
couple of things that I noticed
repeatedly in those people that they
need to improve on usually those people
aren't very good at
um
delegating work they're like protective
over I can do this I can do that you
know they they force through things and
I guess they're not very good at
delegating work down and working as a
team and things like that but overall
they're usually the high performers I
call them the a players everyone has
like businesses have a plays and B
players and I'll not list who they are
today or anything like that I have many
a players and one of the things that I
always say is if you a good business is
based off how many a players they're
having a business so if you have 30
people in your company and
um 15 of them are a players you've got
very good company
I think people usually have what two
three a players
um and it's really hard to get them by
the way
um but yeah I I try to aim as many as
possible
and can you tell in an interview that
someone's going to be an a player or is
it like within a couple of months of
seeing them like when when do you find
out usually I can tell in an interview
and it's usually those three traits I
just mentioned and I usually ask them
when was the last time you pushed
through something to that show tenacity
like you didn't take note you didn't
give up
um have you got any questions curiosity
um and then enthusiasm I just asked them
tell me something that you've done
recently and just see how enthusiastic
they tell and you go you just know that
they are going to be your a players and
you find that that prediction holds true
when when you see them in real life yes
it does the only thing is a players
don't usually stick around because they
become entrepreneurs they usually go and
start their own businesses and that's
what happened with me I had a lot of
people leave and go start businesses
which I'm very proud of I'm like wow
like I hired 100 overall I've hired 140
people in last three years and so many
of them have gone to start their own
businesses and I'm proud of that because
I remember thinking like I want my
people to work here and go and work for
Netflix or Disney or you know amazing
brands or go start their own businesses
and I'll be very very proud and that's
my success metric if I can go and create
that so yeah the fat people have gone
and started their own businesses is a
good thing but it did mean that I had to
constantly replace people because they
they come they learn and then they move
on and go start their own thing and so
yeah a play is a very very valuable but
they're very hard to keep
um we were talking before around
um kind of downsizing the business yes
how was that for you when you had to let
people go really hard
um I build this business I'll run this
business with my heart
um
I was often quite jealous of my
co-founder
um because I felt he ran the business
through money in commercial he looked at
the business with numbers above people's
heads and he admitted that and I think I
used to think that was a superpower
whereas I ran the business through
relationships in my heart and I love
people
um and I found it really hard to let
people go or say sorry there's not a job
anymore whatever it is
um I remember the first person I ever
let go and I cried and I think God I'm
almost like a mess right now and I was
like sorry you know we're gonna have to
let you go and they probably hate me now
but I was like it was very difficult for
me
um I felt like I was letting people down
yep
um so yeah it was difficult but I think
now it's very similar to my early
learnings when I got made with London
it's just business and I've learned to
try teach them it's not personal you're
not bad at your job you're not you know
and I often try recommend people and go
right I can't keep you but I've got you
an interview tomorrow morning at you
know 9 A.M get ready you'll get job and
I'm really I'm really grateful and proud
that there's a lot of instances where
I've got people in jobs straight well I
have mostly people work at right 7 we're
a really good agency so a lot of people
get jobs real fast and but yeah it was
not an easy thing for me to go through
again for for the benefit of people
listening so the people that you've had
to let go not because of redundancy but
because of performance yeah what have
been some of the characteristics of
those sorts of people like things that
people should not do when they're in
their next job or in their current job
um people haven't when they haven't
performed well they haven't spoken up
and being honest I think if these if
they said I'm really struggling with
this can you teach me how to do it or
better or whatever I've missed you know
how to do that and sometimes it is not
just it's not their fault it could be
our fault it's like oh we didn't train
them on that I thought we had you know
so um I think speaking up and being
honest and I think a lot of people leave
it too late and they're being let go and
they're like oh I wish I stepped you
know said something and I wish you said
something too and if they were
struggling with certain roles so I think
yeah don't be afraid to step up and
share your weakness and what you're not
good at
um
another thing I would say is failing to
keep trying I think when you do get a
push back maybe a campaign hasn't worked
or you know you haven't got the results
that you want it's quite easy that
people give up and I think yeah that's
often like a quite a bad trait where
you're like you're gonna get a lot of
pushbacks in business you're gonna get
you're gonna run campaigns that aren't
gonna work but you just gotta keep
trying and learn from those failures so
make sure that you do a review of right
this didn't work out but this is what I
learned and I'm going to apply to my
next kind of you know campaign whatever
it is so yeah I think they're the two
common most common reasons I guess yeah
yeah I think I can really relate to the
the first one you said around like well
where people want to almost feel as if
they're covering up yes things because
they feel like oh I don't want to stick
my head up as being the underperformer
yeah and they probably probably don't
realize that like you're probably
thinking already as a business owner and
then if only they spoke up you would
know okay cool there's an explanation we
can solve this blah blah blah blah yeah
rather than steering on it for two
months and then being like all right
this person has to go 100
yeah we've had a we put out like a q a
thing um for the podcast a little while
ago a question that often came up was
um
advice for women specifically in in the
workplace like do you see any patterns
of like you know to like you know what
women are like versus what men are like
and what yeah both parties I guess can
do differently or quite better yes this
is quite I don't know whether people are
going to like hearing this or
controversial so
um let's talk about the pay Gap
um a lot of people say women are paid
less than men
I actually observe how people behave or
women behave versus men behave and men
are more likely to ask for a pay rise
because they're more confident to ask
for more money women naturally have a
maternal Instinct so they're often open
to doing things for free because it's a
maternal Instinct I'll look after you
I'll do that don't worry about it
without asking for more pay men a lot of
men not like generic but a lot of men
would not do that for free so they're
more likely to go yeah I'll do that but
you can pay me more money to do it
whereas women are less likely to go yeah
I'll do that don't worry about it so I
do think there are certain traits in men
or women that men mean that men do get
more money than women so I guess one
thing that I like to do is tell women
about that
if you can make them aware of it by the
way
you know that guy over there he wouldn't
have done that for free he would have
said you can pay me another 50 Quid or
whatever if I can let women know that
then like oh I didn't realize someone
else would ask for money for that like
I'm happy to do it for free and I'm like
no no so you've got to set those
examples so you do see traits in
different kind of genders and obviously
I'm a woman myself and I can see you
know I do know it exists I've seen the
data of you know gender pay gaps and
things like that but I do see also the
traits that I see in women and men and
how men are more confident to go wait
you want more from me yeah you can pay
me more money
um is there anything else that comes to
mind around women versus men in this in
any of these kind of workplace you
regards yeah so this is something a
little bit different this is more around
like leadership so I have a coach
um and such a female coach and she
basically coaches me about how to be a
good leader good manager and all that
sort of thing and the wheels chatting
one night and that's she's got Nicole
and I said Nicole um
how many how many times you've done this
how many people do you coach you said
carry out I've coached like over 100
people I says what do they vary should
CEOs business owners billionaires
multi-millionaires that sort of thing
she says like that's typically what I go
for so what's the gender split between
50 50 to be fair I don't just look after
women I look after men as well and what
typically do you see in women versus men
and she said this thing she said women
are often
struggle with their confidence in
feeling like they
deserve a place at the table
imposter syndrome they don't feel good
enough they're all always trying to
prove themselves she says that is what
women leaders struggle with men they
really struggle building relationships
with their business with their people
with their propositions they don't
really you know have a a a heartly
relationship with what they do and what
they sell every day and they see it was
a commercial kind of transaction it says
that's usually what people come to me
for when it comes to coaching and I
found that really interesting because I
saw myself in that you know the Imposter
syndrome not feeling good enough proving
myself all that sort of thing but I also
saw my business partner in that because
my business partner and he's actually
left the company now and I went for a
management buyout in November and but
one of the things he really struggled
with is building a relationship with the
business
he just saw it as a commercial you know
transaction that's what he saw it as and
sometimes I envy that because I think if
I didn't have that you know relationship
with the business like I do like it's
driven with my heart I won't get so
upset when someone leaves or whatever or
go for a bad day
um so yeah that's something that I've
seen two different genders in that way
for leadership
so you've you've gone from
kind of growing up on a council estate
to having a you know uh being the owner
of a seven million business which seems
to be a pound which seems to be
continuing to grow yeah how is your
relationship with money changed over
time
um
I still don't pay myself enough and what
I'll say about like I say I'm on a good
salary I ain't good money I like go on
nice holidays like I've been on holiday
I've got time like I do nice things but
I still don't take money out the company
and my boyfriend actually the other day
I was saying oh and we're flying to
Vegas in a couple of months and I've got
a conference I'm talking at and I've
asked him John to come with me and he's
like yeah I'll come with you and we'll
go you know to Vegas whatever and I was
like oh I'm probably gonna have to I'll
pay for your flights though because I
don't want to put it through the
business it's like why are you own the
business why don't you just put it for
the business and I'm like uh it's like I
feel cheeky it's like who do you feel
cheek do you own it oh yeah I think my
relationship with money feels as if it's
not mine still which is really weird
it's like I'm working for somebody else
but I'm also I've always been good with
money I'm never I'm not like the type of
person to get into debts or anything
like that I always work hard to you know
pay what I need
um so I guess my relationship with money
is that I thought money would make me
happier I thought money would you know
it gives me the freedom to do what I
want like the fact I can travel the
world and you know I'm looking at buying
it you know upgrading my house I'm
that's I'm doing all these kind of Life
upgrades at the minute
um but I don't think it's necessarily
changed my perception about the world or
anything like that I don't necessarily
feel any different I guess yeah and I
guess like
the way you value business money is very
different to the way you value your own
money oh yeah 100
um I remember so in our first year
we set ourselves a kpi so 90 of
businesses fail in their first year and
I worked to make sure we weren't one of
them and I guess we gave ourselves the
kpi to make 300 Grand in our first year
because 300 Grand Revenue okay
um 300 Grand revenue is we're making
money
um and it covered um what I forecasted
head-wise like stuff wise to make a
little bit of profit and it was enough
to You Know cover some salary or
whatever but not not enough really to
grow and I remember it was maybe like
three months in after launching we made
300 Grand
and I was like and then I said to the
team if you make 600 Grand then maybe
we'll look at bonuses or something like
that and I said if you make a million
I'll take you all on holiday because I
didn't think we'd make a million we made
1.5 in our first year and that was crazy
but I didn't really understand the
concept of how easy it was to make money
that's a very weird statement to make
and a very outstatement to make but that
money is easy to make and I do think it
is now I know I know it's easy to make
money but the hardest thing is running
the actual business that's a hard thing
and running people and managing people
um but yeah I I didn't realize how
possible it was but what I saw it as all
the time is if I could make money I can
reinvest in the business and keep
growing and keep growing so I've never
taken any big sums you know when people
take money out of the business and buy
these little nice cars I've never done
any of that I've reinvested back in and
grown
um so yeah
yeah one of the things I really know so
I was in um Miami these last two days
for this marketing mastermindy type
thing oh yeah um around and you know if
someone uh people like uh Neil Patel
were there um so they're big SEO type
people yeah people doing like 100
million dollars plus in their agencies
and I'm just like feeling really poor
um but one of the things that was so
interesting about hanging out with that
sort of people doing multi-million multi
tens of Millions with their business and
then it just kind of changes your
attitude towards money and they're just
throwing out oh yeah you know the agent
you know hoping the agency is going to
get acquired by private equity in the
next two years for like 20 XE but uh 250
million something like that yeah and I'm
just like what the hell yeah just the
energy and attitude with which they
approach millions and tens of millions
yeah makes me then feel huh I guess
probably you know but perhaps it's not
it's not that hot yeah whereas back in
the day when I was working as a junior
doctor I was like oh 30k like what a
fantastic salary I was like top 86 of
earners in the country you know that
kind of stuff and I would have just not
realized yeah anyway it's just a kind of
a different way of thinking about money
and in a way it gives you permission to
then sell a ten thousand dollar product
whereas before I'd been like oh my God
this is so much money I can't imagine
and just that attitude with which you
approaching so this is a weird thing so
we went in our second year from three to
seven million and well and going from
second to third year three to seven
million I can't really remember that I
can't really remember how that felt
going from free because that seemed like
a big jump it's more than double you
know and I don't really remember like
seeing or like or witnessing that and I
think like when you get in those bigger
numbers it's it's it feels like if you
can make 50 million you can make 300
million because the difference between
50 million 300 million is not a lot more
because it's actually just you know just
triple that and actually that's easy if
you got to 50 million I'm pretty sure
you can get to 300 billion so when you
talk in those numbers it probably
doesn't it feels like blase but I
remember when I were when we first hit a
million and we actually had a million
cash in the business which is quite rare
to have and usually people spend Cash
Cash goes out the company but we
actually ended up making enough money to
have about a million pounds in cash in
the bank and I opened the bank and
I saw a million pound for the first time
I've never seen you know the actual
numbers I know other than movies like I
saw a million pound and I was like oh
and a screenshot is sent to my mom I was
like have you ever seen a million pound
before and she was like no I said look
at this and it just felt weird for me to
see and I was like this was not in my
personal bank account by the way it was
right the seven of the business and this
cash then was reinvested into the
business to allow it to grow and hire
people you know get offices we've now
expanded out to New York and things like
that so that allowed us to do that
um but yeah I remember my perception of
money just thinking like wow and I still
feel like that to this day like
[Music]
um
I think maybe it'll change maybe I'll
start to think okay I feel a little bit
different when you're hitting your tens
and your 20 Millions like I have friends
now in the industry who are about to
sell businesses for like 200 million I
might
that's crazy yeah like people have to
win lotteries to get there yeah whereas
you've just built an agency I'll say
just like it's hard but still like
it's very rare
um but I think when you learn how to
make money you realize actually it's not
that hard to do it in you just got to
learn how to do it
um okay yeah that was a that was an
interview I was listening to with uh
Alex formosi who you know does a lot of
content and you know 100 million dollar
business owner et cetera et cetera yeah
and one of the questions someone asked
him was hey man you know how do I make
100 Grand a year doing what I love and
he was like dude you know if that was me
I'd spend one day selling 100 uh selling
100 grand for a project to a single
company and then I think what the hell
do I do with the rest of my 364 days of
the year yeah and that just blew my mind
because it's just a way of thinking
about money that's completely different
yeah and with it I think like people I
know who own like 30k 40K a year yeah
are not working any less hard than the
people earning 40 million it's just
they're they're in a different industry
yeah people are earning 40 million are
working hard to sell products to Google
and Facebook and Microsoft exactly
people learning 40K working hard to sell
the same thing or to like a much smaller
business yeah and often it's just like
who is the client that you're working
for yeah which it just completely
changes the multiple that we're talking
about so I I think about this all the
time so my friend is a nurse and she
earns like 32 Grand
and she's like oh you know working day
and night like the NHS is kind of like
grinding her and things like that and
she's like I'm tired I'm like you do
realize if you work those hours in just
in the tech industry you could be doing
200 a year she's like I don't do that
um but I just think it's crazy like
people make these choices and I think
you know you said then around like how
do I make all that money doing something
you love sometimes people do get jobs
that they love but don't make the money
like nursing my friend loves to be a
nurse he was a dream since a child and
but she makes 32 Grand a year and I'm
not saying that bags I think that's a
really good salary by the way
um like my mum's average salary was like
24 Grand most of her life like if you're
earning 30 40 Grand you're ruining a
more than average in the UK wage and I
think people need to recognize that
because I do think there's a lot of like
hustle and grind on YouTube and
Instagram and Tick Tock or whatever
where they're making like 200 Grand and
they're 18 years old I'm like no that is
not normal but we're just more
accessible to it now we just see it more
and whereas yeah a 30 40 Grand salary
that is a good salary
um
what's your what's your end game when it
comes to the business
it's all the businesses
I would prefer to sell into a business
that would give us and my team the
opportunity to go and work on good
bigger Brands you know the Amazons and
the apple and things like that and I
would just merge into that yeah it's not
like I plan to sell and go and Swan off
in the Maldives I plan to just go and do
something bigger and give people bigger
opportunities so I would love to be
honest to merge with a company that does
something the opposite to me so one of
the things I've always learned in
business is don't hire people that can
do the same thing as you hire people
that can do things you can't because if
there's a day where something comes up
and you can't answer the question or do
that thing you've got someone next to
you who can so what I would love to do
is partner with another brand similar to
us you know another agency and go right
you can do the thing we can't we can do
the thing you can't let's partner and
build something bigger and you know I'll
go and own a small share of a bigger pie
yeah that's my dream that's what I would
love to do and I'm mostly about the work
I love the job I get passionate about it
like the fact I can sit in front of a
client now and go so this is how I can
make your lives amazing and fun and you
know come up with marketing strategies
that is going to blow your mind that
excites me rather than anything else
nice
so let's say you do you end up I don't
know either getting private Equity
bought out or most strategic acquisition
or something and I don't know let's say
they offer 200 million and then you've
got 200 million in the bank and you
never need to work again
um how would you spend your time I'd go
start another business
yeah in the same industry or different
or probably different I think now that I
work on a lot of e-commerce and Retail
Brands I've realized I can do that like
I I actually I have a lot of ideas that
I would love to get into e-commerce
start building up my own retail Brands
and things like that and so yeah so I
think I'll probably go down that route
and probably use the money to invest in
other business and see it as like a bit
of a leader and Coach them into doing it
the good thing is now so right I've been
running this business for three and a
half years and we've grown exceptionally
fast to the point where we're on lists
now of the fast one of the fastest
growing businesses and I believe now I
know exactly how to do it I could grow a
lot faster how mad is that I don't need
to grow any faster because I've grown
fast anyway but how now I know exactly
how to do it and what how not to do it I
could teach other people so I'd love to
sit on other businesses and Boards you
know directors Chiefs whatever it is and
you know I can show you exactly how to
run this from P L's to operations to
processes to sales to whatever it is
products and yeah I feel like like what
I'm doing right now is learning so I can
take that somewhere else one day I'm
still only 29.
um so yeah I think the the opportunity
is endless
would 16 year old Carrie have been
surprised by that answer you've got 200
million in the bank and you'll be like
yeah we're going to start another
business yes hello my God like I can't I
I'm very reflective I'm very
um grateful like I'm that type person
like I like still to this day like I go
home to my mum who still lives in a
council state like I said look we're
still in that I'm not yet out of that I
don't necessarily live in a beautiful
house with you know private land or
anything like that that's not where I am
right now I'm still building so I I
might be making millions
um but it's the business that's making
really it's not me personally but I know
one day I'm set up for success I could
sell this business which I I've already
had 40 offers I I have I have weekly
offers coming into my inbox of Agents
other agencies wanted to buy us private
Equity I've had people saying like they
would offer us you know 20 30 million
and so I've I've I'm I'm there that I
could make that money well not there yet
like I I haven't achieved my mission and
you know I think maybe hopefully in five
years time which is crazy because I'll
only be like what 34 or 35 hopefully I
will be in a position where I come and
speak to you and my mum's at that
counselor's day you know
um so yeah so I'm not there yet
um but I know that I'm set up now for
success and if you know if the world
ended tomorrow if rise at seven does not
exist tomorrow because something crazy
happens recession whatever I now know I
can go do something else again I have
full confidence in myself yeah like the
skills you build up along the way you
know yeah and that's where experience
comes in like I wouldn't be able to go
and do that if I didn't have this
you mentioned that the the mission isn't
yet complete what is the mission well
the Corpus behind this stuff
businesses have Mission but I'm my own
personal mission I mean it's my own
personal mission
is
success for me is freedom of other
people's opinions and my own mind
and I'm not you're free of that
how do I get there how do I get free of
my own mind so my own you know when
you've beaten yourself up one night or
whatever it is I'm not there yet I'm
still I still beat myself up that
weren't good enough you know the idea is
not good enough I'm not yet free of my
own mind and I'm not yet free of other
people's opinions so I think I I've got
a long way to get there that's what
success looks like for me that's my
mission and I think I'll be able to get
there through
um just learning learning about myself
learning about people learning about
business and being and then you know
hopefully I'll be 40 50 and go I'm free
of my mind I don't need to tell myself
I'm not good enough Joe I mean because I
know that I am I know that I've built it
so yeah I think that's what success
looks like personally for me
um but I also have this like mission
statement that I want to give confidence
to do to other people to do things
differently I think for me that's what I
realized about myself is I always use my
confidence to do things differently in
my career in University in marketing and
the way that I tweeted that woman to get
that job I had the confidence to do that
and I want to my job and my purpose here
is to give other people that confidence
to do things differently so yeah there's
those two things that I'm I'm kind of
focusing on at the minute
and they're unmeasurable right yeah
exactly I think that's a great place to
end this thank you so much thank you any
final piece of advice let's say
someone's listened to this whole
conversation on YouTube or on whatever
podcast platform and they just really
resonate with what you say
um any any final kind of putting putting
advice for
um
don't let anyone tell you no not even
yourself
love it thank
you all right so that's it for this
week's episode of Deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye